bom dia bom eu sempre fui um cara de
muita sorte muita sorte mesmo
e algumas vezes na minha vida sorte teve
assim um papel muito decisivo
vou falar de alguns eventos pra vocês o
primeiro evento em que a sorte foi muito
marcante pra mim foi quando numa noite
chuvosa meu pai voltando do trabalho
sofreu um acidente de carro se machucou
um pouco
foi pro hospital
minha mãe foi ficar com ele lá e na
manhã do dia seguinte uma manhã de muita
chuva a cidade alagada eu nasci num
parto bem complicado avó cpital e muito
possivelmente se minha mãe não tivesse
entrado em trabalho de parto já no
hospital
possivelmente ela ou eu não teriam
sobrevivido ao papo bom teve um se fosse
um segundo momento de sorte assim
descomunal
quando eu tinha cinco anos de idade eu
fui atropelado por um ônibus sai de casa
correndo sem olhar atravessei a rua o
ônibus que pegou eu vou bater com a
cabeça chegou a cabeça no meio fio
fiquei desacordado e mais nada não
sofreu nenhuma lesão interna não quebrou
nenhum osso foi tudo muito legal no dia
seguinte estava em casa um curativo na
testa e tudo bem
o terceiro momento também muito
interessante de muita sorte foi quando
eu fiquei sem emprego
quando eu terminei o segundo grau eu fui
chamado para trabalhar num lugar que era
bem legal e pagava super bem na verdade
pagava bem porque tinha um adicional de
periculosidade insalubridade que mais do
que dobrava o salário era super perigoso
mesmo e por conta daquele emprego apesar
de ter feito a inscrição eu não ia
conseguir fazer a prova
lá e aí eu saí daquele emprego assim
faltando os 23 dias para a prova do
vestibular
[Música]
tudo bem mas faltavam 23 dias para a
prova do vestibular
eu saí do emprego e aí fui fazer a prova
do vestibular e aí quem vai fazer uma
prova de vestibular sem ter estudado não
tem um compromisso de passar a isso e eu
fiz a prova mais tranquila da minha vida
passei cá e passei pra minha primeira
opção do vestibular não pára aí minha só
não naquele tempo a gente tem mais de 30
anos isso né
todo mundo que prestava vestibular
não importava de quem fosse filho onde
morar se que carreira queria seguir
tinha o primeiro opção estudar aqui
nessa universidade não tinha exceção
na minha época era assim algo parecido
com o enem hoje só que marcava as opções
primeiro nessa escolhendo e todo mundo
começava com a ufrj primeiro semestre de
manhã a e terminava lá aquelas coisas
tipo barrado por aí 5º semestre
madrugada no pessoal que é mais velho
deve se lembrar disso bom porque que
todo mundo queria ufrj bom eu posso
falar por mim são os melhores empregos
eram oferecidos para quem se formava
nessa universidade
então todo mundo queria estudar que era
melhor formação
certamente tinha os melhores professores
aonde a gente aprende a mais e
fundamental era isso
a gente tinha uma promessa de sucesso
profissional é bom estudar na ufrj pra
mim foi espetacular
eu aprendi coisas sobre o que eu não
sabia que existiam disco
descobri um mundo totalmente diferente
aí foi um momento de muita sorte pra mim
gente porque como meus pais não
estudaram meu pai estudou até o terceiro
prima ano primário numa escola rural no
interior de minas gerais
estatisticamente falando as chances de
eu chegar o ensino superior é muito
pequena ainda mais na melhor
universidade que tinha e é sorte gente
porque eu costumo dizer para os meus
amigos que o mundo não é meritocrático
como a gente gostaria na verdade o mundo
é injusto e cruel
a gente tem consciência disso eu
acredito plenamente que pessoas melhor
capacidades capacitadas do que eu até
mais merecedora do que eu certamente
ficaram pelo caminho e eu cheguei na
ufrj bom e aí foi muito legal eu
descobri que existia a pós graduação
mestrado e doutorado realmente eu não
fazia ideia que existia am na minha
cabeça na cabeça do meu pai formado era
quem tinha terminado então ginásio isso
né é estudar depois de formado era uma
coisa que eu não conseguia mais sair
anos mais tarde apliquei e fui aceito
para fazer mestrado aqui na ufrj e esse
foi o evento que mais transformou a
minha vida porque o mestrado me deu uma
formação espetacular coisas que eu
aprendi que eu acho que são definitivos
na construção da minha felicidade
mas o mais importante é que o mestrado
me permitiu alguns anos depois quando eu
estava vivendo um momento muito
frustrante da minha carreira fazer
concurso e virar professor aqui na ufrj
gente e isso é a melhor coisa da minha
vida
primeiro porque a minha vocação é o que
eu faço melhor dizendo que faça bem tá
mais que eu faço melhor é da aula é a
coisa que mais me anima sabe eu pulo da
cama pra vir trabalhar e trabalhar na
universidade é a melhor coisa que pode
assistir pra todo mundo
gente nessa instituição a gente faz o
bem tem coisa melhor que isso
você já pensou como deve ser ruim por
exemplo trabalhar numa fábrica de armas
aqui não aqui a gente tem um propósito
de fazer as pessoas mais felizes e isso
faz muita diferença
então é é uma felicidade enorme
trabalhar aqui eu costumo dizer que ser
professor é o melhor emprego do mundo e
é mesmo bom estou aqui na universidade
devo minha vida ela minha felicidade ela
e como ele falou eu tenho uma família
bem grande né tem aí quatro filhos hoje
não são muito comuns mas aí aqui tem
dois que são do meu primeiro casamento
do primeiro casamento da minha esposa
são os dois mais velhos e mais velho e
dois bebês ao antônio alício antónio vai
fazer 4 a lista vai fazer dois mas há
uns três ou quatro anos atrás quando o
mais velho me disse que não queria
estudar na ufrj
depois daquele momento de raiva neca
gente fica com um
é o primeiro sentimento de pai quando
olha se que é isso k tá eu tomei
consciência de que várias pessoas não
bem mais ao frj como sua primeira opção
várias pessoas legais dependendo da
carreira
dependendo de algumas outras
preferências não vêem mais a ufrj como o
melhor lugar para estudar isso me deixou
um pouco frustrado um pouco apreensivo e
realmente eu passei a pensar o que
precisava acontecer pra que vamos dizer
daqui a uns 13 14 anos quando o
antonialli se estiverem pensando em
escolher onde vão estudar aqueles que
tenham como primeiro
opção essa universidade bom eu acho que
a gente vai ouvir aqui hoje diversos
testemunhos diversas sugestões diversas
coisas super legais sobre o que é
preciso para ter uma universidade legal
mas eu realmente acredito que a
principal mudança é tá na forma como nós
olhamos para a ufrj como nós olhamos
para tudo na nossa vida nos forma como
nós vemos as coisas que a vida nos traz
como os meus eventos de sorte por
exemplo que eu narrei faz toda a
diferença
você pode ter uma atitude mais ou menos
positiva em função das coisas que a vida
se apresenta e pensando nisso na nossa
vida tem algumas coisas que são fruto do
nosso mérito da nossa luta são nossas
conquistas são aquelas coisas que talvez
nem fosse pra nós temos mas nós nos
empenhamos vamos lá batalhamos e
acabamos conquistando isso é muito legal
e é claro que com mais esforço a gente
faz para obter aquilo mais aquilo vale
pra gente mas tem algumas coisas que não
são fruto do nosso mérito na verdade são
fruto do mérito de outra pessoa que
abriu mão em nosso favor que são os
presentes
quando a gente ganha um presente o valor
do presente não vem do esforço claro a
gente não se empenhou para ele o valor
do presente está muito associado na
verdade a quem nos deu presente ao
quanto nós admiramos o estimamos aquela
pessoa que nos presenteou e também um
bocado do quanto nós entendemos que
aquele presente foi caro pra quem nos
presente o presente tem uma coisa
interessante porque ele gera uma dívida
isso não uma dívida necessariamente
retribuiu o presente
uma dívida da forma como você cuida do
presente como você usa aquilo que você
ganhou comunica por respeito e admiração
que você tem porque a gente presenciou a
ritalina reclama disso quando ela cantou
eu te dei meu coração e você o pois na
estante como um troféu não sei quem se
lembra dessa música mas ela está falando
exatamente isso da forma como a gente
trata dos presentes
bom eu realmente acredito que a ufrj é
um presente e é sobre isso que eu quero
falar com vocês
não é um presente de governo não não
presente quando o cliente e aí vou deixa
eu colocar uma coisa pessoal minha na
minha percepção
todo o recurso arrecadado pelo estado
deve ter como meta principal é melhorar
a vida das camadas mais carentes da
população ea gente vive num país como a
população desassistida enorme de
carências infindas também fazer um
parêntese um pouco ante patco gente 12
anos de estudo neste país é elite não
importa onde você mora não importa de
quem você seja filho de 12 anos de
estudo aqui é elite
então todo recurso que vem para a ufrj
deixou de ir sim para hospitais públicos
deixou de ir a programas de combate à
miséria deixou de ir para a educação
básica
e olha não é pouco dinheiro essa coisa
me desculpe universidade gratuita eu
digo para os meus alunos que nada
absolutamente nada de graça
não existe almoço grátis se a gente pois
é na conta a folha de ativos e inativos
da universidade a gente custa 1 torno de
25 mil por ano por aluno
isso é quanto custa uma universidade
cara
aí não é barato não
e na verdade essa universidade tão legal
que é muito legal a gente que está aqui
a gente sabe das coisas que não são tão
legais das coisas que são legais mas
essa universidade de modo geral é muito
legal e é fruto da minha felicidade é
fonte da minha felicidade
ela custa todo dia a gente
o choro de uma mãe no hospital e aí
bom eu acho que quando você olha pra
essa universidade como um presente o que
eu acho que o que naturalmente acontece
se você é aluno
você vai passar a se dedicar ao seu
curso como se fosse realmente a coisa
mais importante do mundo
você vai se preparar tanto para as aulas
que você vai chegar em sala e vai
desafiar os seus professores e nossa eu
posso garantir a você que eles vão ficar
encantados se isso acontecer
ninguém vai pensar em colar as e nunca
vai ver alguém depredando instalações da
ufrj claro que é um presente gente a
gente não quebra a gente cuida com todo
carinho com todo o respeito se você for
docente
eu tenho certeza que não só se vai
entrar em sala para dar melhor aula da
sua vida mas você vai ter consciência
que o seu testemunho ético e moral é
fundamental para a formação da vida dos
nossos alunos
se você é um técnico administrativo e
também reconhece a ufrj como um presente
pra você eu duvido que você
jornada de 30 horas rodízios de falta ou
um certo corporativismo e careta que
ronda determinados lugares que parece um
todo desgosto falo isso parece coisa tá
pior parcela do nosso congresso sabe
aquela coisa asquerosos acho que um ex
aluno que reconhece essa universidade
como um presente
[Música]
ele volta para retribuir a e se deus
quiser um ex-aluno preço cedido quando
eu sei que vocês serão e quem sabe nessa
volta ele não consiga oferecer uma bolsa
para um aluno carente e não consiga
viabilizar por exemplo a maior
democratização dessa universidade
quem sabe então o que eu queria falar
pra vocês hoje é fundamentalmente isso
eu realmente desculpa
pensando na ufrj que eu quero para os
meus filhos é a ufrj que você tenha como
um presente um presente
muito cabo muito caro porque nos é dado
por quem não tem nada
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]